the last time people in wales voted for
their devolved parliament david cameron
was prime minister
brexit hadn't happened and covered 19
didn't even exist
since 2016 it's fair to say a lot has
changed
but will that be reflected in next
thursday's elections
in the 22 years since the first meeting
of the welsh parliament
labour has always been in power here
although not necessarily with a majority
first minister mark drakeford is keen to
capitalize on his record dealing with
the pandemic
but some say that labour's approach in
this campaign has been too modest
well i think we belong in the middle
because that is where the great bulk
of opinion rests in wales the
conservative party in wales does not
believe in wales
it believes in handing wales back to
westminster
montgomery doesn't believe in the united
kingdom it would sever us from
our friends our relations our fellow
workers elsewhere in the uk
it is only the labour party that
believes
in a strong wales in a successful united
kingdom
and far from falling through the cracks
actually that represents
the great bulk of opinion here in wales
in the last four years the conservatives
have gained ground in wales
in the 2019 general election they won
six welsh seats off labour
now labour needs to win back some of
those votes just to maintain their
current standing in the welsh parliament
i think to match our result in 2016
would be a fantastic result for labour
as i said we started the campaign with
opinion polls telling us that labour
would win only 22 seats
to match our 2016 election result
particularly in the current
circumstances i think would be a very
high water mark for us
because uk parliamentary seats in wales
share the same boundaries with those in
the welsh parliament
comparisons between voting patterns are
possible
in the 2016 welsh assembly election
labour held a decisive lead
over the conservatives with 27 seats to
the conservative six
implied comrays six but fast forward to
the 2019 general election
and the conservatives surged to 14 seats
with labour losing out labour are still
expected to make a stronger showing than
the conservatives this time
the latest voting forecasts have them a
good distance ahead but not enough
for a majority because of the gains they
made in 2019
the conservatives should be improving on
the 2016 result
anything less would be a failure we're
fighting every constituency in every
regional ballot
uh we're getting a very good response
indeed it's all about building on 2019 i
accept that and that's why
our strong economic road map out to the
covid crisis is an important part of our
platform
although the polls show people in wales
think highly of first minister mark
drakeford's handling of the pandemic
andrew davies says there isn't much to
celebrate let's not forget that wales
has the highest death rate of any part
of the united kingdom regrettably that's
hardly labour and the welshfort labor
first minister keeping wales
safe let's also remember through the
strength of the union of the united
kingdom
six billion pounds of money has come
into wales to support the fight against
the covid crisis
don't forget pride and labor would have
had as part of the european medicines
agencies which would have had us in the
european vaccination program
rather than actually this successful uk
vaccination program that is opening up
the economy
on all the big questions they have taken
the wrong choices
but this election is a three-horse race
claude camry may hold the balance of
power
hoping to capitalise on a small growth
in support for welsh independence
support is uh increasing indeed
according to some important polls now
even a majority of labour voters
support independence and support for
independence in wales now is
higher than it was in scotland ten years
ago and of course
only a few years later they came within
five percent of winning an independence
referendum and politics is all about
momentum and the momentum is with
the independence movement plaguery and
labour have worked together in the past
could another coalition be on the cards
we're not prepared to concede
uh any other possibility than then
surging support not just for the
independence movement but for play
country if
young people in particular are
supporting independence
and play camry unprecedented numbers if
they turn out to vote
then i think that we are we are looking
at the possibility of a historic
result for montgomery and for wales in
this election that's the prize i'm
keeping my eye
on that prize every bit of my energy is
focused on that
plight clearly didn't want to talk about
possible coalitions just yet
but they might have too soon we've
worked with other parties
in the senate throughout the history of
devolution the current government that's
just ending
had a liberal democrat minister and a
minister who is an independent member
of the senate we've always worked across
party lines
where other progressive parties can
agree on a program for government
and that's always been the way i
approach it i am not interested
at all in political fixes
if we need to work with other parties
let's see
if we can have a progressive programme
for a progressive nation
this is an election full of uncertainty
with seven ukip seats up for grabs
and 16 and 17 year olds voting for the
first time in wales
and if the result is inconclusive which
it may well be
that uncertainty could continue for some
time after as well